so is it possible to say that one side
is worse than the other in in modern
current political
climate listen I'm a person on the left
I'm not pretending to come here as as
and not knowing that my view is biased
because I'm a person of the left if you
ask Ben Shapiro he'll tell you something
different I think in 2023
some total the influence of the American
right wing
if the American right wing were to get
everything it wants
it would be a horrifying reality if the
left were to get everything it wants
we'd have to figure out a few things
including exactly how we pay for certain
programs
but they're mostly noble goals and I
believe that they are more supportive of
an individual
self-determining what they want to do in
life and how they want to live and is
more in line with the idea of freedom
and liberty than what the right is
currently proposing that's my view